So somebody that that's applying for
a job in a startup hopefully
knows what they're going into.
It's a very different environment
compensation wise clearly, but
also the scope of work and
what every person gets to work on.
The good news is startup work and
big corporate work
are very different things.
Not good or bad just different.
And I think employees recognize that.
Making sure you explain what it takes
to be an employer in your startup,
how it's different than
Company X perhaps that
that person worked with before and
just as important,
acknowledging the risks Identified in
corporate perhaps there's less risk.
In start up life
significantly more risk, but
also greater rewards if
the start up does well.
So making sure the employee understand
that risk reward balance and
how that shifts between corporate
to start up is really critical.